tonight I have the pleasure of
introducing dr. Larry Schweikart Larry
Schweikart is a historian author and
television producer he received his BA
and MA from Arizona State University and
his PhD from the University of
California Santa Barbara from 1985 to
2016
dr. Schweickart taught history at the
University of Dayton his articles have
appeared in numerous academic journals
including Business History Review
Journal of southern history and the
Journal of economic history his PBS
documentary rocking the wall considered
rock music's role in bringing down the
Berlin Wall
he is co-author with Mike Allen of a
Patriots history of the United States
and the author of several other books
including seven events that make excuse
me made America America 48 liberal lies
about American history and how Trump won
forthcoming in January 2018 please join
me in welcoming dr. Larry Schweikart
Thank You Maddie there's an old rock and
roller I can scream over anything's I
wasn't concerned about the microphone
but thank you again for having me back
to Hillsdale thanks to Doug Jefferies
for putting all this together and
although he's not here I'd like to thank
Burt Folsom I suspect he had a hand in
my invitation here
seems like throughout my career when big
things have happened
Burt Folsom was always behind them so I
owe him a particular debt of gratitude
Jerry by the way how Trump won which
Maddy referred to came out last January
and I'll get into that later in the talk
this is let's just jump right in this
could be a pretty boring talk I mean
it's about taxes you know one of my
favorite movies is meet Joe Black a
night yeah a 1998 film with Brad Pitt
Anthony Hopkins and Pitt plays death in
the form of a young man who's killed by
a car I need a body bill and Hopkins
plays bill a multi-millionaire who's led
an exemplary life loving his daughters
and building his business death grants
bill one a little bit more time if bill
will just show him the ways of the world
what it means to be alive in the
climactic scene bill has been betrayed
by his daughter's boyfriend drew who's
attempting an inside takeover death is
taking bill that night to his final
resting place but bill asked just enough
time to thwart drew when drew meets bill
and Joe death tells bill I'm gonna tell
him who I am tonight and of course bill
no no don't don't do that looking
straight at drew death says I am an
agent of the IRS
anyone who got that joke for many people
you know what it's like to be told
you're about to be audited by the IRS
it's almost as bad as death Americans
have had issues with taxation for a very
very long time each colony had its own
taxation policy including excise taxes
import taxes poll taxes and property
taxes and there were not many tax
revolts in colonial times prior to the
French and Indian War remember this as a
time of British government governance
known as benign neglect but after that
changes in the British Imperial policy
in 1763 American colonists and the
British government were constantly
fighting over taxes given that most
Americans were farmers it shouldn't be
surprising that most of those battles
were over taxes on food products
including sugar and tea and if you're
mayor deblasio big gulps it shouldn't be
indeed other than the infamous Stamp Act
of 1765 the Tea Act became the most
resisted tax in colonial history of
course the most ironic thing about the
Tea Act was that officially lowered the
price of tea but simultaneously it
greatly expanded the enforcement of
merchants meaning that colonists would
no longer be able to buy the much
cheaper smuggled tea
hence the actual price of team went up
for most people and yes there were other
tea parties in other towns that we never
heard of because Sam Adams wasn't around
to write about those tea parties
most historians of the American
Revolution conclude that no specific tax
not even the Tea Act caused the American
Revolution so much as the process by
which that taxes were imposed virtually
all the British duties fell on merchants
or ship owners who passed the costs
along to consumers that meant that at
least initially few outside of those
groups had many concerns about taxes
going up or down during the war the
Second Continental Congress placed
requisition
on the states and the states usually
ignored these requests instead as most
of you know Congress simply printed
money to finance the war in 1777 under
the new Articles of Confederation
Congress and article 8 allowed for
levying taxes but approval was left to
the states no national taxes were yet
considered lacking a national taxation
system Congress turned to it's only
marketable resource land with the land
ordinance of 1785 Congress banked on the
natural resources and the new nation to
finance its operations the states
continued to resist any form of Taxation
on them meanwhile the states owed the
federal government and when the
Massachusetts state of Massachusetts for
example raised property taxes to pay off
the national government the burden fell
on the Western farmers and led to Shay's
rebellion ultimately Shay's rebellion
led to debtor relief legislation in that
state but there was no question that
fiscal issues helped prompt calls for a
national constitutional convention once
a convention met founders recalled their
experiences with King George and
Parliament which were all imposed
without the consent of the governed or
any participation by the general public
hence the war was over in the colonists
established a constitutional republic
with all taxation power originating in a
House of Representatives the legislative
body closest to the people it was a tax
regime that lasted until the Civil War
and it consisted of two main
characteristics first that the non
national entities would handle most of
the taxation states and localities would
until about 1863 constitute the major
funding source for any government
activities second factor was that the
u.s. government determined to use the
great expanse of landed assets which
produced as taxation historian Eliot
Brownlee called the creation of the
assets state as well as a pure fiscal
state this necessarily produced some
contradictions
Americans did not dislike property taxes
and in fact generally saw them as a
legitimate way to fund public activities
but there did exist a tremendous as we
noted a well-founded suspicion of
national government taxation powers
especially in the form of a direct tax
on individuals Madison in Federalist ten
expressed his concern about factions and
the quote the most common and durable
source of factions he said would be
quote the various and unequal
distribution of property thus in the
Constitution reflecting Madison's ideas
all duties and impose were to be uniform
throughout the United States so that
Congress could not single out any
particular group for punishment through
taxation
moreover Madison was himself suspicious
of the power of the federal government
hence the Constitution prohibited a
direct tax on individuals instead based
on Alexander Hamilton's fiscal plans the
United States would rely on two revenue
sources the ongoing sale of public lands
and a new import tariff system Hamilton
has been greatly misunderstood
particularly I think by conservatives he
hated debt and sought to establish good
credit for the United States not
perpetual debt his sinking fund would
have required Congress to use an
American Express form of paying off the
existing debt before new debt could be
incurred but even the tariffs themselves
are usually mischaracterized the goal in
Hamilton's mind was to protect infant
American industries see cry
conservatives he wanted to pick winners
and losers in business not at all
Hamilton's two most emphasized
industries to protect were iron and
textiles both of which were critical to
national defense
Hamilton knew that in any war especially
any war arising soon the young Republic
would need both iron for cannon and
muskets and textiles for uniforms to
survive too Hamilton it was a national
issue not an economic or business issue
as he said the ultimate goal must make
the United States self-sufficient in
arms and to support quote an annual
purchase of military weapons to aid the
formation of Arsenal's unquote from the
adoption of the Constitution to the war
of 1812 the most heated controversies
involved excise taxes as opposed to
tariffs but Hamilton went too far
instituting an excise tax against a
particular group of farmers leading to
the whiskey rebellion yet another
food-related tax nevertheless the result
of the Hamiltonian program to all but a
few of the most virulent Hamilton haters
was a solid fiscal structure that served
the young Republic extremely well and
was allowed his despised rival Thomas
Jefferson to reduce the national debt
significantly until it was entirely
expunged by another empty Hamiltonian
Andrew Jackson
thus in one of the great ironies of
history both small government which they
really weren't Jefferson and Jackson
ended up beholden to the big government
Hamilton's ideas in order to shrink
government meanwhile under James Madison
the federal government activated the
lesser known half of the three-fifths
compromise where in three out of every
five slaves slaves were counted for
purposes of both representation and
Taxation now most of you know about the
representation part it gave the south a
permanent advantage up to the Civil War
in Congress some historians have
estimated that the voting power of the
south in the house was increased by
about six percent up to about 1861 the
taxation part of the compromise was
seldom used
but Madison's administration imposed
direct taxes on slaves houses and land
all via the states so there still was no
direct tax from the federal government
to an individual Madison continued
Hamilton's a low tariff policies but in
1824 after the Federalist Party was gone
Congress enacted a 35% tax on imported
iron wool cotton as
raw materials such as hemp flax molasses
and lead how damaging this tariff was to
American industry and consumers has been
debated and is murky due to the lack of
sources in 1828 an increase created in
the massive outcry from the South in
particular and was known as the tariff
of abominations ultimately reduced
through compromises by 1842 the Walker
tariff reduced rates to 1816 levels
where most Americans had not objected to
them as brownly again put it quote to
the American public when tariffs were
low they seemed to represent a
legitimate and reasonable exercise of
power by the federal government at the
same time public lands provided an
enormous buffer against taxation the
land ordinance provided for the orderly
distribution of land but Americans being
Americans we just rushed off into
unsurveyed land providing possibly the
greatest threat to law and order and the
nation's stability in its young history
wisely based on common law the Articles
Congress chose to follow the lead of the
people if they wanted to settle an area
before surveys were completed you can
see starts right down there in southern
Ohio Congress allowed this through a
system called preemption which we know
today better as squatter's rights this
proved to be one of the four pillars of
American exceptionalism that Dave
Doherty and I outlined in our book a
Patriots history of the modern world
it's truly the first time government
bowed to the will of national behavior
rather than demanding people tailor
their behavior to the national law the
founders proved even more brilliant by
instantly understanding that land
without political representation meant
nothing so they provided a path to
citizenship with a subsequent Northwest
Ordinance of 1787 taken together the
land ordinance of 85 and the Northwest
Ordinance of 87 were astounding pieces
of legislation that at the time no
nation on earth had even considered but
land sales remained in the hands of the
federal government while projects such
as canals and railroads were built at
the state level once again although
taxes themselves proved too little to
fully finance such ventures States
partnered with individual businesses by
offering loan guarantees in what was
known as the canal era before long
however railroads exceeded even the
ability of states to provide finance
again wisely the states mostly avoided
entanglements with the railroads which
in turn set off a whole new revolution
that we today call the managerial
revolution in American business this not
only radically changed business in
America but leapfrog across the Atlantic
to the rest of the developed world in
short both the national and state
governments found ingenious ways to
avoid taxing ordinary citizens in the
process forcing American businesses to
adapt and overcome Republicans who by
now replace the Whigs continue to
campaign on a few industrial tariffs
mostly iron and textiles and these
issues provided the basis for key
support in northern states and for the
rapid expansion of the Republican Party
among working groups even before Abraham
Lincoln took office in 1861 Republicans
passed the Morril tariff a major
reversal of lowering rates but even that
proved inadequate for what was about to
descend on the United States Abraham
Lincoln won a highly contested election
in 1860 and the south promptly seceded
soon South Carolinians began firing on
Fort Sumter and the war was on civil war
placed a staggering new burden on the US
government for funds and an unbearable
one on the Confederate States of America
federal expenditures soared from 2
percent of GNP to almost 15 percent of
GNP this is salmon chase Secretary of
the Treasury
who names a kid
salmon hey what's his sister's name
perch brother trout you know you may
know that the Admiral Pearl Harbor was
named husband Kimmel now can you imagine
you're a wife and you're taking husband
to a party this is my husband husband
Brad to meet you meet you anyway neither
land sales nor tariffs could raise
sufficient money to fight the war in the
short term leading secretary of the
Treasury Chase to examine a wartime
taxation system in July 1861 Congress
created the federal government's first
national direct tax and realized that
gaining popular support for new taxation
to replace the tariff was a major public
relations task Congress ruled out a
large-scale property tax and turned to
an income tax like its successor in in
1913 in August 1861 the income tax had
two components that would be easier to
sell to voters rates were low three
percent maximum and there were generous
personal exemptions up to then $800
which would be you know hundreds of
thousands of dollars today which would
lead large numbers of Americans outside
the taxpaying system yet even that
proved inadequate to support the soaring
cost of the vast armies in the field
quickly Congress increased the rate with
a second tier of 5%
sound familiar and enacted consumption
sales taxes creating an office of the
Commissioner of Internal Revenue
with quote the largest government
department ever created to date they
hiked import duties that raise the top
rate again by 1865 revenues of 61
million in a single year a counter for
21 percent of federal revenues while
tariffs accounted for slightly more 29
percent borrowing and printing
greenbacks filled out the rest
slowly excise taxes were phased out and
Congress allowed the wartime income tax
to expire in 1872
I just included this image because it
triggers so many people on the PC any
snowflakes out there like the
Confederacy of course enacted its own
tax but without the collection
superstructure of the Union government
this proved a major problem the South
relied on its states to collect
Confederate taxes and states simply
didn't want to do it as a result the
Confederacy collected a paltry eight
percent of all the money it needed to
fight the war from taxes instead the
Confederacy turned to inflation and most
of you know how that story turned out
the Confederacy's money became worthless
taxes it seems are the worst way to
finance government operations except for
the alternative at least one historian
Douglas Vall placed the blame for the
Confederate defeat squarely on its
failure to establish a working financial
structure after the war high tariffs
remained a dominated post war finances
over land sales but in 1913 with the
Underwood tariffs and this no relation
to Kevin Spacey and Frank Underwood some
of you might think that rates were
substantial that rates are substantially
reduced but the problem with tariffs
even beyond the philosophical issues
free marketers have with them was nearly
insurmountable as the nation grew
fairness demanded more and more
businesses and industries receive some
protection somewhere if everybody had to
pay for higher price products then it
was reason everyone should benefit from
their own products being price protected
practically speaking this of course was
a disaster
congressional committees battled over
1/2 percent increases in the duty on
flax or LED or copper or any other
product that had a constituency
someplace determining fair rates got to
be too much work for Congress indeed as
we see today any work is likely to be
too much work for Congress and as always
legislators search for an alternative so
they didn't have to take the heat from
revising rates regularly at the same
time the government developed a very bad
habit
in the form of wartime consumption taxes
on certain luxury products which now
more than ever meant injecting morality
into the taxation system taxes on
alcohol for example became increasingly
popular for it allowed Congress to
reduce tariff rates while imposing a
financial punishment for sin others
argued that in fact taxing sinful
products protected them from abolition
and that booze could never be prohibited
as long as it was being taxed
I recommend a fascinating fictional book
to you by Kyle Mills he has taken over
the Vince Flynn Mitch wrap series and in
smokescreen the tobacco industry finally
gets fed up with over-regulation and
demands that the federal government
either ban cigarettes altogether or let
them be sold with like any other product
and until that happens in the book the
tobacco industry goes on strike you can
imagine what fun that would be
you ought to see what happens when
millions of smokers suddenly can't get
their ciggies or when the government to
use Ronald Reagan's term can't get its
tax revenue at any rate you can see that
raising government revenue has multiple
components each affecting voter
constituencies some often contradictory
with others the Republican Party was
known as pro-business because it
supported the gold standard but it was
also viewed as Pro labor because it
supported tariffs the Democrats are
known as the party of low taxation
because they oppose tariffs but instead
favored simply printing money the issue
came to a head in the election of 1896
when gold standard advocate William
McKinley ran against the opponent of the
gold standard William Jennings Bryan he
made his famous Cross of gold speech and
lost
however some party realignment had
already begun as the Democrats had begun
picking up poor farmers in the south and
west and adding immigrants to their
rings at the same time large
corporations became tainted as too big
and were assailed as monopolies whether
they were or not authors such as Henry
George progress and poverty
began to call for property taxes on
profits in the price of land popular
pressure for redesigning the tax system
began to build especially in the farm
sector that's still represented about
half of America as taxes storing Eliot
Bradley concedes support for a radical
progressive income tax had more to do
with the search for social justice in an
industrializing nation than for an
elastic source of revenue gee that bears
repeating because it usually is still
true today arguments about taxation have
very little to do with paying
government's bills and more to do with
making people at the bottom feel like
they're sticking it to somebody at the
tongue this was a founding component of
evil that still affects us today
progressivism or the view that man in
human societies are perfectible in the
here and now if only we established the
right system were the right person at
the controls when Democrats got control
of both houses of Congress in 1893 they
promptly pass a new income tax with a
separate tax on corporations it lasted
about a year until the US Supreme Court
struck it down as unconstitutional in
1895 in [ __ ] the farmers loan and
Trust Company progressive historians
have railed that this was yet one more
example of the elites establishing quote
an anti redistributed principle into
constitutional law it was already there
obviously the major challenge for the
progresses was that they had to change
the constitution by then many
Republicans had become fans of the
income tax including Teddy Roosevelt
William Howard Taft did tell you a story
about Taft when he was the governor of
the Philippines he got sick and he
cabled back to Washington to Elihu root
says took ill wrote a horse up to a
mountain retreat to recover wrote back
housed the horse
Taft was about 350 pounds
anyway so we got tr we got Taft we got
Robert LaFollette they saw this as a
means to not corporate interest down a
peg while retaining the support of the
working groups they got support from
farmers who resented the constant
increases in farm property taxes states
had already made inroads into finding
new taxes so trying to get ahead of
popular sentiment many wealthy people
signed on to the taxation provision
including a group of quote urban
economist and attorneys who were tax
experts including Edwin are a Seligmann
of Columbia University and Charles J
Bullock of Harvard senator Nelson
Aldrich led the charge for the 16th
amendment secretly hoping it would fail
ratification in the States the measure
faced defeats and delays that ultimately
benefited it when a new single-payer tax
system was proposed causing fence
sitters to see the income tax is
preferable to single-payer the income
tax measure was enacted as part of the
Underwood Simmons tariff act of 1913
which slashed tariff rates and made up
the revenue with the income tax this is
the first income tax form the whole form
it was deviously clever in its design
and appeal to ordinary people first
exempted many Americans entirely with
rates starting at $3,000 now back then
that was that was just a ton of money
after that rate started at a half a
percent at the lowest bracket and topped
out at 6% when I lived in Ohio year and
a half ago our state income tax was six
and a half percent this is this
astonishing level given that many states
alone had high rates meant that few
people would pay the tax and those who
did wouldn't pay very much at all
second the tax is extremely easy to
comply with its form being only one page
I've heard Rush Limbaugh say his annual
Tax Forum annual forum is 2400 pages
anyway it worked
since people had become convinced that
equal taxes meant proportional taxes the
income tax promise to quote equalize tax
burdens borne by the various classes and
ensure it was paid by the wealthiest
classes the income tax had as one
proponent said quote little to do with
revenue and everything to do with reform
while some liberal historians have
complained that the income tax was quote
a conservative measure designed to
placate the lower classes with a pretend
form of punishment of the rich it didn't
help ordinary Americans by 2013 those
ordinary Americans worked until April
18th every year just to pay the federal
taxes whereas that same American only
worked till January 19th each year to
purchase all the food he would eat in a
year
similarly tax payment day the day taxes
were due was put at April 15th nearly as
far away from an election on either side
of the calendar as humanly possible now
when I am elected dictator of America in
2024 my personal government reform is I
will move tax day to November 1st right
before the election and oh you must pay
all taxes in cash or cheque that would
stop high taxes in a hurry even then
politicians didn't think income taxes
would become a major source of revenue
for the federal government but no one
counted on World War one almost
instantly in the low rates of 1913
skyrocketed up to 65 percent for the
wealthiest remember their rate was 6 and
a 30% for the lowest bracket up from 1/2
corporate rates doubled only about 15%
of Americans paid all the income taxes
so those wishing to soak the rich were
in fact very successful as if that
weren't enough there was an excessive
profits tax that made up 2/3 of all
federal revenue during the war the
system was pure redistribution as Wilson
administration proudly admitted Woodrow
Wilson as administrators overreached and
failed to build any consensus for the
new structure which was quickly repealed
and
scaled back dramatically by a successor
Warren Harding and his secretary of the
Treasury Andrew Mellon Republicans cut
the top rate on the rich from seventy
eight percent to fifty eight percent
then more finally arriving at twenty
five percent this was an astounding
slashing of taxes but note this after
mellon worked his magic rates were four
times higher than where the system
started Mellon correctly claimed that
quote the prosperity the middle and
lower classes depended on the good
fortunes and light taxes of the rich he
was famous for the rising tide theory
that a rising tide lifted all boats and
that tax cuts spurt investment because
wealthy people and business owners had
more money to invest and expand their
businesses it's common sense
I used to ask my students how many of
you have ever gotten a job from a
homeless person
nobody ever raised a hand the answer of
course is none while this may vary my
own limited experience in running a
little film company suggested a business
needs to reach a level of about a
million dollars capitalization to
reliably sustain a single employee in
2017 Mellon aware that his political
opponents would seek to renew their
progressive tax increases convinced
businesses to accept some progressivity
in the system by preserving the estate
tax and the corporate tax both terrible
ideas while certainly not all Harding's
are melons or Calvin Coolidge is doing
the decade was known as the Roaring
Twenties and businesses had more money
to invest government revenues fell some
but not much and both Harding and
Coolidge Coolidge chopped spending so
the United States had a surplus
everybody say that after me
surplus okay surplus right United States
had a surplus for most of the decade and
in 1926 saw the unemployment rate reach
an astounding 1.6 percent even
anti-republican historians such as Ellie
Brownlee glumly admit the national debt
shrank steadily for ten years under the
Republicans from 25.5 bill
in 1919 to 16 billion in 1930 in fact as
a share of GDP shrinkage was even more
amazing by from 33 percent down to 16
percent if the tax cuts hadn't exactly
quote paid for themselves they'd get a
heck of a job
oh and that fairness thing the share of
taxes paid by the rich in 1921 was 29
percent but in 1926 after the tax cuts
51 percent and the share paid by the
bottom bracket fell from 21 percent to a
mere 5 percent now how's that for
fairness you enter the Great Depression
and Herbert Hoover a statist and static
scoring president who was Franklin
Roosevelt Ritz small although he forced
a minor tax cut through after the
Depression hit he offset that with
government expenditures driving up
deficits even past had Congress pass a
check tax tax on every check you wrote
while Hoover exacerbated the economic
conditions most economists blame horrid
Federal Reserve policies for contracting
the money supply which had already done
through the 1920s in real terms
Democrats in Congress gleefully repealed
the Harding Coolidge Mellon cuts pushing
the top rate to 63% and passing a
national sales tax Democrats also
increase the estate tax
pushing the effective rate on top payers
to the highest levels in ten years and
the depression continued the new
president 1932 Franklin D Roosevelt made
no secret of his intent to soak the rich
and further ensured the depression
lingered his administration added still
more taxes to an economy already unable
to achieve liftoff there was a tax on
dividends a tax on food processing
increases in capital gains and other
taxes Roosevelt embodied the essence of
the phrase tax and spin in World War two
FDR pushed through a dangerous
withholding program that concealed the
burden of taxes from ordinary people in
a comedy show in the 1980s designing
women' anybody remember that
showed designing women designing women
had was about some women who ran a
design and architectural firm and one of
the women a wealthy woman named Suzanne
Sugarbaker at one point found herself
forced to take a regular job when she
got her first paycheck she exclaimed
who's this FICA guy and why is he taking
all my money precisely go back to my
suggestion that people pay their taxes
by cheque or cash during World War two
high taxes were tolerable because of
patriotism and also because consumers
could not purchase much creating a
massive pool of hit up demand for
consumer items after the war with
nothing to buy and with wages steady
thanks to government controls the
American public put up with a tax regime
of course the flipside was enormous dip
which piled on top of FDR's New Deal
debts by 1943 the annual annual deficit
was 57 billion dollars and increasingly
taxes made up a larger share of federal
expenditures more tax money meant more
federal spending rising from 10 percent
1940 to 15 percent a decade later as a
nation emerge from World War two a new
Liberal Democrat tax regime had masked
based progressive personal income tax a
flat tax on corporate income and a
regressive payroll tax for Social
Security as American businesses regained
its footing confidence in 1950s however
a new push to reduce burdensome tax
rates appeared John F Kennedy answered
the call Kennedy subscribed to Mellon
supply-side concepts so named because
the tax cuts on the wealthy would
stimulate the supply side such as
investment building factories
supply-side was based on sales law that
says that supply creates its own demand
meaning not that by making a product
will it lead to that particular product
being purchased but that the
expenditures created in making that
product would be enough to purchase it
if desired the money would be spent
somewhere
although JFK would not live to see it
the Revenue Act of 1964 the
to across-the-board cuts of twenty to
thirty percent even with a Vietnam War
escalating the economy turned around and
again proved the concept of supply-side
cuts for the Bible says in the mouth of
two or three witnesses and now we had to
melon and JFK Ronald Reagan would
provide the third in the 1970s
Keynesianism was largely debunked
through the disproving of the Phillips
curve which said high inflation high
employment could not coexist by the mid
seventies all Americans knew it
absolutely wasn't true government
expenditures only added to inflation did
not seem to affect unemployment at all
by the end of the 70s Jimmy Carter as
had Gerald Ford before him failed
helplessly with tansy and approaches to
stop inflation and simultaneously
restart the economy Reagan had come to
the supply-side in the 1970s from
reading a number of sources but his
biggest thinking on his biggest
influence on his thinking on taxation
was from personal experience from
incredibly high rates he once paid as an
actor he knew intuitively that high
taxation discouraged work initiative and
rewarded purchases of non-taxable assets
Arthur Laffer of the University of
Chicago had already outlined his Laffer
curve ostensibly on a napkin although he
couldn't recall that as a means to
dismiss the bias the basic argument is
not serious
liberals kind of forgot that the Beatles
wrote yesterday on a napkin or that in
Dayton at a place called the engineers
Club you have a frame tablecloth outside
where some of the most brilliant
engineers on the planet would draw their
designs for incredible inventions the
Laffer curve was a simple basic
illustration of the true principle that
there are two levels at which government
will receive no tax revenue zero and a
hundred percent no one will willingly be
a slave although I think Donna Brazile
said she did something like that laugher
said that at some point and he didn't
specify where the government would get
more revenues by lowering tax
this is common sense he used the burden
of taxes to explain once a reagan used
the burden of taxes once to explain to
his son Michael how he couldn't raise
Michaels allowance buttress by work from
Heritage Foundation Reagan planned a
large 30 percent across-the-board
immediate tax cut upon entering office
originally devised by representative
jack kemp of New York Senator William
Roth stretched it over three years no
one ever said that tax cuts would pay
for themselves but by that time the sad
notion was already ensconced that tax
cuts had to pay for themselves somehow
the post-war Republicans in reaction to
FDR had wedded themselves to the concept
that every dollar of reduced taxes had
to be paid for with some other revenue
source of course deficits never have to
be paid for but nevertheless prior to
Reagan assuming the presidency though
the anti-tax sentiment in America had
achieved a dramatic victory in
California with proposition 13 this was
a true tax payer revolt against bracket
creep which inflated property values
late ever escalating tax levels on
homeowners prop 13 limited tax rates on
property to 1% of market value and
required a two-thirds majority in each
house of the legislature to increase
taxes piggybacking on this taxpayer
revolution Reagan stormed into office
and his economic recovery program had
the Kemp Roth cuts in the forefront
Reagan also sought new depreciation
scales that benefit businesses of course
static scoring budget balancers like
Alan Greenspan fretted about deficits
and urged Reagan to stretch out the cuts
Reagan refused as one tax historian said
the president wanted to cut everyone's
taxes regardless of whether or not they
had any particular economic theory to
back him up this was vintage Reagan who
knew instinctively what worked he
expressed this in a joke about three men
a surgeon an engineer and an economist
who died and went to heaven
st. Peter said they only had
room for one of them based on who was
the oldest profession surgeon said well
God removed the rib from Adam to make
Eve so I should get in the engineers
said well hold on
God made order out of chaos what do you
think engineers do I should get in the
economist said well who do you think
caused the chaos eventually the final
agreement was for a five ten ten
reduction on individual rates and
capital gains of twenty percent
but as the notion that would lead to
great written but as to the notion that
it would lead to greater revenues even
Regan a file such as dinesh d'souza
seemed to think revenue fell while in
fact during Reagan's eight years
government revenues rose eventually by
40 percent and by nineteen eighty eight
the economy is generating more tax
revenue at a maximum rate of twenty
eight percent than many on the Left
forecast to generate at seventy percent
and deficit still rose because G
Congress kept spending Congress spent a
hundred percent more was an object
lesson that taxes and deficits are not
related and even the deficit relented it
fell from six point three percent of GNP
and eighty three the pit of the
recession to three percent by 87 to 89
or right where it was
before the tax cuts America's economy
soared GNP rose 30 percent median income
which had fallen in the 70s rose fifteen
percent some five million new businesses
were added and twenty million net new
jobs were created interest rates were
cut in half inflation nearly disappeared
in some quarters about five percent more
of those in the middle class earning
between 15 and 50 thousand moved into
the next highest quintile than before
causing critic Kevin Phillips to
scornfully note quote the term
millionaire has become meaningless now
let me go off-script I tell my students
all the time that our textbooks are
horribly bias in any students out there
have used a book called the American
Pageant and your history books got one
over here
how about
the national experience Big Blue Book
okay this is from the American Pageant I
don't have the title up here but the
title of the chapters is rigged in the
chapter and Reaganomics or whatever and
this is deficits over time if I could
put a title up here to be deficits over
time okay so check check this out you
obviously see that from 1985 to 85 or
from 80 80 to 85 and on to 88 deficits
just go kind of off the charts here this
is just nuts what's that crazy old
Reagan doing gee whiz
except there's something wrong with the
chart this is taken straight out of the
book by the way note up top it says
billions of dollars uh-huh Zorin missing
real this is not billions of real
dollars this is billions of inflated
dollars any economists worth his salt
knows that you always adjust money over
time for real dollars so I got their
data and I did that then I said you know
how much you owe is a factor of how much
you make I mean if some of these
students in here saw my visa bill they
pass out on the other hand if Bill Gates
on my visa bill eats a throw it in a
pile until it amounts to some real money
you know I'll pay up maybe in three or
four months so I adjusted this in real
dollars as a share of GNP here's the
chart now these guys are historians
they're not economists it was just a
mistake
maybe they just screwed up right no same
book same topic I eat Reagan's an idiot
okay this is the national debt over time
but they went a step further any of you
I know it's not required watching
anymore any of you remember Sesame
Street leaves have this thing three of
these things is kind of the same thing
one of these things is not quite the
same and they have a parakeet and a
parakeet and a parakeet and a ba
constrictor
Susie what's different well that's a pod
constrictor
okay so let's play the Sesame Street
game here note the bars we have
depression that's an event World War two
breaks out
that's an event Japan surrenders event
Korean War event Vietnam War event gran
a person see how clever they are in this
this was done deliberately this is done
delay and it's utterly utterly flood
here's the real chart I overlaid them
it's not a perfect over I didn't overlay
those two guys sorry I must have dropped
the overlay chart but you get the point
you get the point as for that equality
thing after the Reagan tax cuts just as
happened under Harding mellon Coolidge
just have another JFK the rich ended up
paying more of the total share of taxes
the poor and middle class less in fact
according to a study by James Courtney
and Richard Shoop the rich ended up
paying a whopping four and a half times
more than before the cuts
this may sound counterintuitive but it
kind of is like driving on ice you know
when you go into a skid which way do you
turn into the skid huh
hey die I don't care you want to live
turn into the skid Reagan eventually
gave in to the deficit hysterics with a
tax revision in 86 which in his mind was
mostly about closing loopholes
nevertheless as always reform meant
raising tax rates for most Americans and
the rates jumps back to 32% for
individuals and 33% for corporations and
the deficits never changed now we're
back to these guys I did not have sex
with that woman miss Lewinsky I did not
have sex with her he was talking to
Monica I did not have sex with that
woman miss Lewinsky no no it's me and
you know it's always me anyway
yo you'll get it Reagan's successor
George HW Bush committed political
suicide by reneging on making his read
my lips no new taxes pledge made at the
Republican convention Bush tried to
justify it as a necessary fix for
resisting Saddam Hussein and Kuwait but
the essence of the promise was destroyed
taxes would go up once again a
Republican had been browbeaten over a
deficit that Democrats never cared about
when they were in office once again it
did little to change the deficit but did
contribute to Americans saying bush is
unreliable and some people thought the
tax hikes contributed to the recession
in 1990 Bush's opponent in the election
Bill Clinton got the message and ran on
tax cuts for the middle class combined
with tax increases on the wealthy he
proceeded to spearhead five separate tax
increases the largest series of
peacetime tax increase in American
history outside the New Deal and as
might well been predicted his
middle-class tax cuts went by the
wayside reaction of Clinton's overreach
in 1994 led to the first Republican
majority in the House of Representatives
in 40 years and produced the contract
with america which called for a balanced
federal budget led by Georgia
congressman and Speaker Newt Gingrich
the house proposed aus-8 tax a
value-added tax that would keep income
taxes at current levels but would allow
unlimited deductions for savings and a
credit for Social Security taxes however
it also proposed an 11% VAT Congressman
Dick Armey instead suggested a flat tax
as close to a return to the original
1913 form as you could have asked for
Gingrich and Senator Bob Dole appointed
a commission chaired by jack kemp to
review the entire US tax program and
possibly repeal the income tax Democrats
resisted the flax tax elements and by
then it was 1996 a presidential election
year and Clinton balked at jumping
onboard tax reform concentrating on
short-term issues and running against
both Democrats and Republicans called
triangulation
but Gingrich had succeeded in getting
more protections for taxpayers and the
Internal Revenue Service restructuring
and Reform Act in 98
it also streamlined the IRS making it a
more effective collection machine than
ever while business rates remain at
about 86 levels through much of the
1990s individual rates crept back up
although the national debt had still
climbed under Clinton he claimed credit
for a slight budget surplus in 2010
weren't convinced the Democrat policies
toward them and elected George W Bush
narrowly Bush ran on a substantial cut
of 1.3 trillion including reductions in
almost all brackets some by 30 percent
and included a doubling of the child tax
credit to a thousand per child
but unlike Reagan the economy was not a
major issue for Bush America was not in
a recession and had in fact done well in
the Clinton years especially Silicon
Valley took off whatever plans Bush had
were largely derailed by the events of
9/11 the subsequent war on terror and
the invasion of Iraq politically Bush
simply refused to fight back against a
negative press a tactic his strategic
adviser Karl Rove called quote the
biggest mistake of our presidency the
result was that by 2006 Bush was
substantially weakened and he took the
Republican party down with him
Democrats won the Senate and in 2008 the
election of Barack Obama held a
veto-proof majority in both houses Obama
ran on extending the Bush tax cuts only
for those who made under 250,000 a year
after he won Congress passed the
American Reinvestment Recovery Act about
a third of which were tax cuts he
immediately offset that with massive
government expenditures that had no
impact on the economy the biggest tax
was yet to come Obamacare the Affordable
Care Act with a myriad of taxes on
everything from medical devices to
services almost all at the whim of the
Secretary of Health and Human Services
deficit soared and Republicans found
their issue for 2010 repeal Obamacare
and cut taxes indeed Republicans are
mobilized by a new
emergence grassroots group the Tea Party
and Tea Party stands for what taxed
enough already which soon dominated the
core of the Republican state parties
however it be claimed became clear that
while Tea Parties could elect people
they're a little less successful in
forcing them to keep their word
at local levels tea parties often not
always proved inept at governing despite
three consecutive Tea Party elections
the anti-tax message was paid
lip-service but little else Donald Trump
won in 2016 in part on the basis of tax
reform and still the Republican
establishment and utterly unanimous
Democrat opposition have stalled any tax
cuts but we are now into current events
not history and the tides swirling
around the Republicans unwillingness or
futility to achieve anything with
electro majorities goes far beyond taxes
let me give you in closing just a few
personal proprietary pieces of research
to wrap this up as to where we're
heading in 2016 I wrote a book called
how Trump won with Joel Pollak of
Breitbart I wrote my sections on in this
book before 2016 long before election
day I predicted a trump victory and I
quote of between 300 and 320 electoral
votes in spring of 2016 how did I do
this was not speculation it was based on
extensive voter registration analysis in
key states for example I found that in
Ohio in Cuyahoga County
there had been massive shifts by the
summer of 2016 how massive Ohio election
center on three or four cities Cleveland
for Democrats Cincinnati for Republicans
swing areas of Columbus and Dayton for a
Democrat to win Ohio they had to come
out of Cuyahoga County at least a
hundred and fifty thousand to the good I
found that in early summer 2016
Democrats had lost 92 thousand off their
roles in Cuyahoga
County Trump Scott Ohio it's simply
impossible for Democrats to win the
state other statistics over the summer
confirmed my expectations in Iowa in
Florida in North Carolina everywhere
Democrat registrations and/or early
absentee voting were drastically off
2012 numbers we could in some instances
even predict with great certainty how
independent voters would vote based on
very deep house-by-house voting patterns
my conclusion was that Trump would
easily win Ohio he actually won by 5
points more than I thought that he would
pretty easily win North Carolina Iowa
Florida and based on the makeup of the
voting population of Ohio that he would
carry Michigan and Pennsylvania the only
state I did not call was Wisconsin I put
all this in drafts that I sent to
publishers in October and I was laughed
out of the office of course the day
after the election I started getting
calls but the story isn't over and yes
it relates to taxes and everything else
I continued my research into voting
patterns and registration since November
the numbers are shocking they are
completely unreported in the national
news largely ignored even by Republican
hierarchies because of the story they
tell since November the net change in
registrations in 14 battleground states
where we can track Democrat Republican
registrations are awesome and they are
all in one direction toward Republicans
sometimes total registrations and states
are down because secretaries of states
purged the rolls of dead people out
migration otherwise known as Democrats
but up down are sideways the numbers are
stunning in 12 of the 14 states
Republicans have gained and gained a lot
again since November in Arizona
supposedly trending blue Republicans
have had a net gain of twelve thousand
over Democrats in Florida 62,000 it's a
trend about 6,000 per month which means
that current rates always you know at
current rates you are going to be
looking at Florida being a red state in
2020 this is critical because so far
neither national part oh yeah I almost
forgot
Pennsylvania 109,000 net shift to
Republicans since November North
Carolina 80,000 are the only states that
are trending Democrat Colorado a little
bit Delaware by 300 people okay the bad
ones count California's a million new
Democrat registration since the election
but again they won't they're 55
electoral votes aren't going to change
because they get more right this is
critical because so far neither national
party has figured this out both are in
denial because this entire surge I would
argue is Trump populist Tea Party surge
in my dozens of speeches all around the
country I find no enthusiasm for the
Republican Party per se it's all about
Trump and the change he represents
including a more reasonable tax system I
think any chance of a true flat tax
unfortunately is non-existent I'm not
particularly a supporter of the
so-called fair tax which I think has
even less chance to see the light of day
so that brings us back here the IRS will
be with us all till death but the system
can and if my statistics are right will
be made better and sooner rather than
later Joe Black may end up
looking like Brad Pitt after all
[Applause]